au coeur d'une base militaire le père
andriy aumônier dans l'armée ukrainienne
offre à ces soldats sont à ces quelques
instants de répit
derniers moments de paix avant de
rejoindre l'est pour défendre le dombass
[Musique]
les églises sont les rares endroits où
vous trouverez toujours du soutien
ici est le père andré
sandrzyk
il est de tous ceux qui viennent la nuit
pour les soutenir j'essaie de garder le
sourire pour leur envoyer des ondes
positives et un peu de joie dieu m'aide
toujours à choisir les bons mots pour
leur apporter mon soutien
en ce dimanche des rameaux la cérémonie
se termine par la bénédiction de
circonstance
contre de départ au front lemonnier
collecte de l'aide humanitaire
médicaments vivres vêtements toutes
sortes de produits de première nécessité
sont ensuite redistribuées
nous venons ici prendre des médicaments
pour nos soldats pour les remettre sur
pied les soigner
et de quoi faire les premiers soins par
la foi sans l'action ne vaut rien donc
là où il ya la foi est ici bas il y as
seront faits pour aider les gens au
quotidien 9 min propre ligne son show
hier le père andry et plus ainsi que le
guerrier mais dans quelques jours il
rejoindra une nouvelle fois
les tranchées du donbass certains
soldats viennent me voir et me demande
où est mon arbre alors je sors ma croix
et je leur dis voilà mon arme
s'il ya bien une chose que vladimir
poutine est réussie en ukraine c'est
d'unifier une nation jusque là divisés
russophone russophobe orthodoxes
catholiques juifs et musulmans
s'apprêtent ensemble a livré la plus
importante bataille de l'histoire de ce
jeune pays pour le contrôle du donbass